التخطيط لرحلة ولكنك تريد التأكد من
تغطيتك في حالة الإلغاء ،
يمكن أن يمنح تأمين السفر للمستهلكين
راحة البال
، يقول مكتب الأعمال الأفضل إن
تأمين السفر يمكن أن يحمي مشترياتك
من الرحلات المحتملة الملغاة أو
تغيير مسارات الرحلة ،
لكن تحذيرًا لن تفعل كل السياسات
إلغاء التغطية بسبب مخاوف صحية
أو
سوء الأحوال الجوية ، ولكن بعض ما يتم
تغطيته عادةً يشمل
إلغاء الرحلة أو تأخير الأمتعة المفقودة أو
المسروقة.
إذا كنت مغطى
في حالة المرض أو
السرقة وإذا تغيرت التغطية إذا كنت
تسافر دوليًا ،
فهذا مهم بشكل خاص إذا كنت أنت أو
أولئك
الذين تسافر معهم يعانون من ظروف صحية
يقول معهد معلومات التأمين إنه
يتوقع أن يدفع ما بين
خمسة إلى سبعة  في المائة من تكلفة
رحلتك وقبل الشراء ، قم
بأبحاثك عن الشركة التي تريدها
للتأكد من أنك تبحث عن أشياء مثل
الشكاوى والمراجعات المحتملة
وقبل شراء تأمين السفر ، تعرف على
الفرق بين
التأمين والتنازل عن الإلغاء
بينما توفر التنازلات
بعض الحماية من إلغاء الرحلة ، فهي
تتضمن عمومًا
المزيد من القيود على مراقبة المستهلك.